I went to a thing with Dean graciosi  who's Tony Robbins like right hand man  we went to his house and he had like  three people that week heard stalker you  know weird stuff and I was like dude how  are you willing to put up with it like I  just I never want to be that famous I  want no one to know me I want to be rich  as hell and that's it and I was very  committed to that he said if that's the  price I have to pay to make the impact I  want to have I'll do it every day of the  week and he just looked at me and I just  remember just feeling it in my chest I  have to do this and I started making  YouTube videos shortly thereafter that  was kind of the beginning of me starting  to post